[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lors d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sûreté des
soixante dix huit bienvenue dans cette
édition du 7 8 journal tout de suite les
titres de ce lundi 29 janvier un pic de
crue comparables voire supérieurs sur
certains secteurs par rapport à juin
2016 les inondations continuent de
toucher les yvelines à la montée des
eaux va se poursuivre jusqu'à mercredi
sur le secteur des boucles de seine dans
ce journal on fait le point sur les
interventions des pompiers dans le
département
la députée porte parole du gouvernement
aurore bergé présenté ses voeux la
semaine dernière à rambouillet cérémonie
en présence de françois de rugy
le président de l'assemblée nationale a
pu évoquer avec les élus la prochaine
réforme constitutionnelle les détails à
suivre
enfin c est chaque mois dans le cetud
j'en à le dossier de la rédaction cette
semaine nous mettons en lumière la
culture urbaine dans les yvelines et on
débute ce soir en musique avec la fripe
hop un style développé depuis 2001 par à
l'artiste de trappes à bout à suivre
dans ce set 8 journal une interview du
lieutenant-colonel petitjean il est chef
du groupement opérations aux 10 60 18
les pompiers des yvelines on parlera
bien sûr avec lui à des inondations et
des à différentes interventions qu'ont
pu faire les pompiers ce week end dans
le département
une conséquence indirecte à des de ces
inondations elles concernent les
transports la le trafic de la ligne a du
rer c est stoppé sur cette station à
paris et ça c'est jusqu'au lundi à 5
février minimum
tout comme pour trois gars du
département versailles chantiers sans
cire et saint quentin en yvelines à
cause de l'inondation qui concerne la
station javel à paris je vous propose
dorénavant de lire cette phrase les huit
prochaines années vont être difficiles
pour nos clients et d'ici 2025 il y à 22
autres gars 2
grand paris express interconnecté avec
le réseau sncf prévu c'est une
déclaration d'alain cracovie tch
interrogé par nos confrères du parisien
le directeur général de transilien le
reconnaît à la circulation des trains
sera encore plus fortement perturbée
dans les prochaines années en ile de
france
de nombreux chantiers de rénovation ou
de création de réseaux dans le cadre du
grand paris express vont se tenir dans
un laps de temps très serrés et des
lignes seront notamment coupé pendant
plusieurs jours pour pallier ces
difficultés la sncf compte sur un
renfort de l'offre de transport et à des
services de bus de substitution
le mouvement est devenue l'an passé la
première force politique législative
dans les yvelines la république en
marche 78 présentait ses voeux samedi à
ses militants elle cérémonie qui se
tenait à villennes sur seine en présence
de plusieurs députés notamment nadia et
jean-noël barrot didier baichère ou
encore florent ce grand juge aurore
bergé elle organiser sa cérémonie des
voeux c'était jeudi dernier à
rambouillet la députée porte parole du
gouvernement a convié les chefs
d'entreprises représentants
d'associations et élus de sa 10e
circonscription et le président de
l'assemblée nationale a fait le
déplacement pour parler notamment de la
réforme constitutionnelle est les
détails avec ce sujet de nicolas landry
une veste rouge pour un invité de marque
la députée aurore bergé a convié à ses
voeux le président de l'assemblée
nationale françois de rugy
une cérémonie sous le signe de la
collaboration entre la députée et les
élus locaux sur cinquante et une commune
ce soir elles toutes les communes
étaient représentées par l'intermédiaire
de leurs élus locaux y avait plus 30 mer
ce soir
ce qui veut dire quand même quand on a
réussi à créer un lien sur ce territoire
un bloc communal venus avec des
revendications sur la baisse des
dotations de l'état
et cet argent
flv sur les coûts de fonctionnement je
peux même pas d'investir on les attend
le maire de maurepas grégory cariste ya
échangé avec le président de l'assemblée
nationale notamment sur la prochaine
réforme de la constitution
une réforme sur laquelle l'élu sera
vigilant les collectivités
les intercommunalités les communes les
départements et les régions ont été
mises à mal ces dernières années avec
une baisse de financement drastique qui
entachent depuis très longtemps
maintenant la libre administration des
collectivités
françois de rugy a profité de la tribune
pour présenter sa vision de la réforme
constitutionnelle
la réforme de la constitution c'est en
effet l'occasion de donner plus de
liberté aux collectivités locales
si on veut que les collectivités locales
soient plus efficaces face des économies
disons le eh bien il faut leur donner
davantage de liberté et d'autonomie dans
leur gestion notamment dans la gestion
du personnel et puis faut aussi être
capable d'innover
on n'est pas obligé d'administrer la
france de la même façon quand on est en
milieu rural en montagne dans une zone
touristique ou dans une grande ville
cette réforme voulue par le président de
la république devrait être présenté au
printemps
deux options sont possibles pour
l'adopter le vote à la majorité des
trois cinquièmes des parlementaires
réunis en congrès où un référendum et je
vous le disais en début d'édition parle
des inondations dans ce journal avec mon
invité d'honneur rejoint plateau c'est
le lieutenant-colonel petit vent bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le chef du groupement
opérations aux 10 78 les pompiers donc
des yvelines merci d'être avec nous dans
ce journal et surtout on imagine avec
cet emploi du temps très chargé en ce
moment alors les yvelines qui sont
toujours placés en vigilance orange
inondations dans un tel événement
lieutenant-colonel comment s'organise le
travail des pompiers notamment en lien
avec la préfecture et les différentes
mairies des yvelines le travail des
sapeurs pompiers des yvelines en fait
aujourd'hui et dans la reconnaissance
notamment des zones inondées puisque
nous sommes toujours dans une phase de
montée des eaux
une reconnaissance pour déterminer
l'accessibilité notamment aux zones
inondées pour assurer toujours nos
secours avec efficacité mais également
d'assister la population dans des mises
en sécurité sécurisé aussi on va dire
toutes les structures communales qui
participent à la mise en sécurité des
différentes installations et aider et
des habitants en zones inondées voilà
essentiellement
co concerne consiste le travail des
sapeurs pompiers surtout dans cette
période de montée des eaux alors du côté
de la préfecture il ya ce qu'on appelle
un centre opérationnel départemental qui
est mise en place est ce que les
pompiers des yvelines ils participent ou
de votre côté vous avez également un
centre opérationnel nord tout à fait
dans le cadre de l'organisation de cette
opération et cet événement climatique
le centre opérationnel départemental est
activée sous la digue sous la direction
du préfet dans ce centre opérationnel
départemental on y retrouve
l'intégralité de tous les services
concernés d'accord et notamment on y
retrouve les sapeurs pompiers les
sapeurs-pompiers ont leur pendant à
savoir qu'actuellement nous avons un
poste de commandement départemental
activé au centre opérationnel à
versailles qui coordonne l'action de
deux postes de commandements de zones on
va dire de secteur 1 / magnanville et
l'autre sur saint germain en laye et qui
eux-mêmes coordonne l'action de 17
centres d'incendié et de secours
notamment ceux du bassin de la seine qui
actuellement sont activés armée en
nombre puisque nous avons aujourd'hui
450 sapeurs pompiers sur l'ensemble du
département qui oeuvrent au quotidien et
de là nous avons en moyenne 80
sapeurs-pompiers engagés par jour alors
vous en avez dit deux mots la crue n'est
pas terminée cet épisode n'est pas
terminée dans les yvelines le pic était
attendue aujourd'hui sur le secteur
c'est le parvis mercredi pour le secteur
boucles de seine donc après conflans
sainte honorine
quel bilan vous vous tirez sur ces
derniers jours dans les yvelines
notamment ce week-end et cette journée
de lundi quel bilan en terme
d'intervention vous tirez sur sur le
département des arts le bilan de nos
interventions puisque nous sommes en
état d' alerte depuis le 22 janvier
dernier nous nous sommes intervenus à
plus de 200 reprises pour mener des
actions de mise en sécurité d'assistance
d'évacuation mais également de
reconnaissance comme je le disais au
préalable 200 interventions dans la
phase de montée des eaux c'est ça semble
peu mais ça représente un nombre
d'heures conséquences sur le terrain de
manière à en partenariat avec les autres
services et faut bien le souligner c'est
une action inter service va être de
gérer ces inondations dans un domaine de
la gestion de crise qu'on appelle c'est
important après il y aura effectivement
la montée des eaux il y aura la décrue
où nous passerons dans une autre phase
opérationnelle à savoir
notamment dans la protection des biens
et certainement dans des opérations de
pompage spécifiques notamment dans les
établissements d'hier enjeux en termes
de montée des eaux on l'a dit dans dans
les titres la crue et est similaire
voire même supérieure à haut niveau de
juin 2016 du comté du côté des
interventions des pompiers ce qu'on est
sur du sur le même ordre est-ce que
c'est comparable finalement est ce que
vous avez pu faire comme intervention il
ya deux ans alors la crue de juin 2016
et et a été différente de celle
d'aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans une
crue hivernale avec une sciatique
relativement lente par rapport à 2016
qui va s'inscrire d'ailleurs dans le
temps à la différence de 2016 qui a été
une montée des eaux assez assez soudaine
et avec une décrue aussi rapide par le
fait que nous étions en sortie de
printemps
là en l'occurrence ça va durer plus
longtemps les cinétiques beaucoup plus
lente ce qui veut dire que nous nous
mettons les moyens nous pouvons nous
adapter beaucoup plus facilement qu'à
une montée rapide des eaux
quoi qu'il en soit le les sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines en fait sont
malgré toi guérir en eau non
l'expérience puisque les inondations
même si depuis quinze ans il n'avait pas
eu réellement nous étions déjà dans la
culture du sapeur pompiers des yvelines
aguerris aux inondations une dernière
chose lieutenant colonel a dit donc la
montée des eaux qui se poursuit pic de
crue aujourd'hui sur le secteur seine
paris qui va se poursuivre donc ce pic
de crue sur le secteur boucles de seine
d'ici mercredi
donc des personnes qui vont être
confrontés ou qui sont déjà confrontés à
ces situations d'inondations quels
conseils vous pouvez leur leurs données
pour voilà être en toute sécurité ne pas
prendre de risques
face à ces inondations alors de bien
prendre en compte
les consignes de sécurité de leur
commune en tout cas de leur mère puisque
chaque mère il ya 57 communes qui sont
concernés par un par les inondations
beaucoup de communes ont déclenché ce
qu'on appelle leur plan communal de
sauvegarde y en a 27 voix sur les landes
avec avec derrière des consignes bien
précises notamment de comportement à
adopter notamment sur les crues pendant
les crues en tant que sapeur-pompier
j'invite forcément tous les coûts des
sinistres et quelque part ou en tout cas
tous les gens évoluant dans la saison 2
de cru être très vigilants notamment
lorsqu'ils évoluent en zone inondée
parce qu'il ya des risques
il ya des risques importants notamment
par le biais par le biais des du courant
que peu qu'on va heurter certains
endroits des passes qui peuvent se créer
peuvent être facilement emporté dans la
montée des eaux est donc tous ces bons
conseils également que les prévisions
les dernières infos vous pouvez voulait
aller retrouver pardon sur le site de la
préfecture des yvelines qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran tout comme sur le site à
12 10 78 merci lieutenant-colonel
petitjean d'avoir été avec nous merci je
rappelle chef du groupement opérations
aux 10 78 on reprend le cours normal de
ce journal le mouvement on en a parlé
tout à l'heure est devenue l'an passé la
première force politique législatif dans
les yvelines c'est la république en
marche une députée de la république en
marche aurore bergé organisée également
sa cérémonie de voeux
on en a également parlé
je passe à autre chose le budget 2010 8
qui a été validé par don par le conseil
à départementale des yvelines les élus
l'ont votée en séance ce vendredi
dernier à versailles un budget primitif
qui s'élève à 1,4 milliard d'euros dont
une enveloppe de près de 400 millions
d'euros pour des projets
d'investissement le département s'est
fixé un objectif et baisser les impôts
locaux d'ici 2021 explications au micro
de maxime le maine pour le conseil
départemental jesi mais ce qu'on retient
de ce budget c'est qu'on a fait tous des
efforts
les contribuables qui ont fait un effort
très violent lorsque l'état s'est
brutalement désengager je rappelle que
nous sommes le département unique en
france où l'état supprimé 90% de sonnets
de principal qu'est la dotation globale
de fonctionnement 135 millions d'euros
que cette décision brutale nous a
obligés à une augmentation brutale de
l'impôt mais que la maîtrise de nos
dépenses de fonctionnement tout à la
croissance l'investissement nous
permettra à court terme de rendre aux
yvelinois une partie de cet effort
politique toujours la fédération des
yvelines du front national recevait hier
dimanche jean messia c'est le conseiller
spécial de marine le pen
en ligne de mire la refondation du parti
les équipes souhaitent comprendre les
derniers échecs lors des élections
présidentielle et législatives ils ont
donné pour cela hier la parole à leurs
électeurs reportage de nicolas landry et
léa riches
une part de galette des rois pour
évoquer l'avenir du front national c'est
ce qui était organisée dimanche dernier
à coignières la fédération fn des
yvelines recevait le conseiller spécial
de marine le pen jean missia dans le
cadre de sa mission d'ambassadeur de la
refondation
vous savez la refondation c'est pas
simplement de venir faire des critiques
marine a voulu que ce soit une
entreprise extrêmement ambitieuse où les
gens non seulement font des critiques
sur ce qui ne fonctionne pas mais soit
capable aussi d'apporter des
propositions pour les améliorer parce
que sinon c'est trop facile
autour de jean missia de jeunes
personnalités du parti étaient présentes
comme mathilde andrew et la responsable
départementale
l'occasion d'évoquer les points
primordiaux au bon fonctionnement du
parti
évidemment ils ont partagé avec une
grand nombre de français la déception du
débat présidentiel à qu'ils ont donc il
pour eux un manque de technicité donc
flies à izon les vraies attentes sur des
experts on a connu depuis ses 4 5
dernières années une croissance
exponentielle en terme de deux suffrages
en termes d'adhésion à nos idées et il
est absolument nécessaire de
professionnaliser toutes nos équipes
après des mois difficiles le front
national ne cesse de vouloir rebondir en
ligne de mire notamment les élections
européennes en 2019 puis les municipales
en 2020 pour rappel c'est dans les
yvelines à mantes-la-ville que le fn
détient sa seule municipalité
d'ile-de-france comme fin comme chaque
fin de mois pardon sur tv 60,18 le
dossier de la rédaction
cette semaine nous vous proposons à des
reportages sur la culture urbaine dans
le département on débute ce soir en
musique avec un artiste originaire de
trappes
abou a commencé en faisant du rap je
suis à développer son propre style
musical à la fri pop
il prépare d'ailleurs son prochain album
intitulé à free pop spirit est nicolas
landry est allé à sa rencontre dans son
studio faire penser en faisant danser
c'est l'esprit des compositions dabou
cet artiste évinois de 42 ans originaire
de trappes prépare son prochain album
afri pop spirit dans son studio il
travaille sur un morceau en particulier
bamako boss
[Musique]
après avoir composé la musique et écrit
son texte à bout peut commencer à
enregistrer
c'est le troisième couplet de la chanson
et c'est parti dans la cabine
si la gutta plus d'ajouter c'est
peut-être que toi même tu a fauté non
faut pas fait ça tapait la doudou sinon
le dieu peut te botter en réalité légaux
ce sont les boss
si tu as le doute montreux moi comment
tu peux à coucher grâce à son studio 223
abou peu procédé au mixage
place ensuite à la première écoute et
donc là je vous faire écouter donc après
le travail justement de mx qu'est ce que
cela donne avant le mastering ses
tonalités ses textes sa rythmique
caractérise son style la fripe hop un
genre musical développé depuis 2001
en 2007 il sort son premier ep le
nouveau souffle de la fri pop en 2010
son premier album a free world color
avec un slogan une musique qui tu
ressembles rassemble et à rien ne
ressemble sachant que l'idée c'est
vraiment essayé de rassembler les
personnes qu rassembler les peuples
rassembler les personnes surtout qu'ils
ont au delà de sa couleur de peau sa
classe sociale est ta religion c'est en
fait une couleur d'esprit qui nous
rassemble avec des valeurs c'est
vraiment un mélange entre la world music
et la musique urbaine à savoir que moi
je chante en fait en français et en
bambara qui est une langue du mali sur
des beats parfois que son hip hop
d'autres un peu plus sale ça c'est
vraiment un mélange entre eux world
music et musiques urbaines à bout peut
s'inspirer de risma partir d'une musique
pour ensuite ajouté sa patte
werner elle ne rend fou alors en 12 jeux
serait sauvé la vie théâtre elle m'avait
il faut vraiment être dans mon labo à
pourra faire un petit peu tout est
ensuite envoyé ce que moi j'ai envie de
faire entendre de ma propre création
sans que quelqu'un il ya rajouté quoi
que ce soit qui dénature un peu ce que
j'ai envie de vous présenter la fripe up
c'est aussi aider des jeunes à
développer leur projet musical ce soir à
bourg soit six tirs rappeur d'elancourt
le travail va durer une partie de la
soirée en ces temps d'hiver où l'on
parle bien sûr de mauvais temps mais
vous avez aussi entendu tout à l'heure
en début de ce journal d'inondations il
se peut que vous ayez le moral dans les
chaussettes alors pourquoi pas vous
tourner vers la calinothérapie pour en
parler avec moi sur ce plateau nouvel
invité hélène le vent bonsoir vous êtes
la créatrice du site câline attitude
alors vous êtes yvelinoise vous vivez
après 12 ans alors qu'elle une attitude
c'est le premier site français de mise
en relation de personne pour des séances
de calino thérapie rémunéré alors juste
avant de présenter ce site si on parle
un peu de votre parcours vous étiez dans
le domaine de la sécurité nucléaire
avant de vous orienter vers la
naturopathie pourquoi pourquoi ce
changement de voix qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie de changer de voie tout à
fait donc ça faisait un petit moment que
j'étais dans le nucléaire est une
opportunité s'est proposé à moi pour
justement travaillé dans la naturopathie
donc je suis donc en formation de
reconversion depuis deux ans et je me
suis également intéressé donc aux
bienfaits de la cao thérapie en
parallèle alors vous allez être
intéressés donc aux câlins pourquoi le
cas l'an justement alors parce que ça a
de nombreux bienfaits donc notamment ça
libère donc l'ocytocine une hormone du
bien-être ça nous permet de nous re nous
et à nos émotions de rebooster le
système immunitaire et externe anti
stress naturel donc plein de bienfaits
pour pour le canal envie de créer ce
site
voilà de calinothérapie rémunéré l'idée
vous est venu comment alors c'était
suite un reportage j'ai vu que c'était
beaucoup développée dans nos pays
voisins
donc je me suis un peu renseigné en
france il existe des baraques à l'un ou
des ateliers de qualité rapide mais pas
encore de 6 des mises en relation
donc pourquoi pas mettre ces personnes
souhaitant bénéficier des bienfaits des
câlins en relation entre elles
vous l'avez dit c'est développer dans
d'autres pays notamment en amérique du
nord ici pas de bêtises c'est ça et est
du coup le le concept vous avez eu en
ville d'exporter en france fita fait
alors vous avez parlé des bienfaits des
câlins alors ce site propose de la
câlinothérapie rémunérés on pense quand
on pense qu'alain au mouvement aussi des
free hugs ces gens dans la rue qui ont
pu proposer des câlins aux personnes qui
étaient peut-être en manque d'affection
là pourquoi le proposer sous formule
rémunérer justement parce que le câliner
en fin de compte va proposer un service
donc il se faire énuméré du fait que ça
sort hors du contexte familial outre et
qui sont-ils justement c'est personnes
qui vont proposer des câlins ça pourrait
s'appeler tout le monde
à partir du moment que la personne soit
majeur sans limite d'âge avec
bienveillance
tout le monde peut s'inscrire donc pour
offrir ses services de calinothérapie
mais nous enfin de l'autre côté aussi
les personnes qui sont
manque d' infections peuvent aussi
prendre contact avec ces personnes
seront profil de câliner alors une
question peut-être un petit peu tabou je
ne sais pas mais ça peut prêter à
confusion les la calinothérapie
rémunérés on peut on peut penser à
d'autres d'autres choses des formes de
proxénétisme peut-être qu est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous répondez vous à ça à
ce qu'on est ce que c'est ddd jugement
qu'on a pu qu'on a pu vous faire à la
création de ce site
alors moi je partirai du sens que déjà
la seule des riffs probable ce soit que
c'est que le site se transforme un site
de rencontres d'une part et d'autre part
moi j'insiste bien sur le fait du mot
qu'alain donc c'est uniquement prendre
une personne dans ses bras et le
réconforter sommes vraiment toujours en
bienveillance alors sur le
fonctionnement du site vous en avez dit
deux mots concrètement comment ça
fonctionne comment fonctionne ce site
câline attitude alors le système est
assez simple vous avez le choix entre
deux profils en câline euros câliner
sachant que le câline heures propose
donc une séance de calinothérapie le
câliner va se faire câliner vous avez
une fiche profil a renseigné donc un
pseudo votre âge votre ville un petit
descriptif sur vous une photo et ensuite
vous pouvez à l'aide d'une recherche
avancée contacter d'autres profite donc
à dinéault câliner autour de vous il
vous entrez en contact avec lui à savoir
donc l'adresse mail ne sera pas dévoilée
sur le site et ensuite il vous restera à
convenir avec la personne d'un
rendez-vous du vieux
du tarif et du temps de la séance vous
voulez dicale inler et câline est ce que
les tarifs des séances justement vont
varier selon lesquelles une heure où
est-ce que gas et une fourchette qui a
établi par le site libre choix là et
donc du coup et c'est c'est c'est aux
essais à la libre discrétion et du
câline heures on rappelle donc les
bienfaits des câlins faisant les dynamos
anti stress ça libère l'ocytocine vous
dit ça brise aussi la solitude c'est on
peut se sentir seuls à avoir besoin
d'affection tout à fait voilà ça permet
de nous rejouer aux autres qu'est ce que
vous espérez de ce site il a été lancé
il ya combien de temps c'est tout
nouveau il ya une semaine à peine allait
alors maintenant c'est le but c'est de
le développer j'imagine tel développer
voire de le faire connaître et puis que
les personnes s'intéressent vraiment à
ça qu'ils aient qui prennent plus en
compte les jugements des autres voilà
qu'ils fassent attraction à tout ça et
qu'ils viennent profiter des bienfaits
d'accueil aux thérapies et justement si
vous êtes en manque d'affection que
voulaient au contraire donner de votre
affection vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
site internet kalin attitude qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci à vous
et hélène devant d'abord être avec toi
merci je rappelle la créatrice de ce
site kalina kalinka link aline
attitude.fr pardon je le cite c'est
câline attitude voilà j'ai dit
calinothérapie c'est bien câline
attitude.fr merci d'avoir été avec nous
le sport ou plus précisément lice porte
maintenant avec cette grande première à
versailles habitué au conseil municipal
ou au cérémonie officielle à l'hôtel de
ville a accueilli ce week-end un tournoi
de jeux vidéo des centaines de joueurs
se sont affrontés sur l'univers médiéval
fantastique
hairston retour sur cet événement avec
nickel et demi d'euros et nicolas
d'envoi 32 ordinateurs des écrans géants
l'hôtel de ville de versailles s'est
transformé en une salle d'arcade gironde
ce samedi 27 janvier
au programme une compétition du célèbre
jeu médiéval fantastique
aston et discipline pratiquée par plus
de 70 millions de joueurs à travers le
monde
on a un père aux différents
le but c'est de faire dès qu un paquet
de 34 ont réuni notre offre meilleure
car on choisit le héros qu'on veut et on
confond de notre héros au héros adverses
et on va avoir un système de points de
vie la pandémie c'est notre vie et le
but ça va être de mettre les points de
vie réduite à zéro pour ce premier
rendez vous du sport tas versailles 2
compétition était organisée en parallèle
la première réunit ces huit des
meilleurs joueurs de france
tous professionnels pré sélectionnés
parmi plus de 1000 candidats
la seconde et est ouverte et des joueurs
amateurs nous on considère que dans les
jeux vidéo
les gens ont l'habitude d'être actif
devant leur écran et donc on considère
que quand ils viennent c'est juste pour
regarder les joueurs
et ben voilà il vous regardez une heure
et vous regardez deux heures et du bon
bout d'un moment ils vont repartir et
donc ce mix des deux fait que les
joueurs jouent leur parti regardez
partie de projets de leur parti et c'est
souvent quelque chose qui marche très
très bien
amateurs ou professionnels tous ont joué
cette compétition intensément comme de
véritables sportifs
certains joueurs se sont entraînés
pendant plusieurs semaines pour réaliser
des performances sur ce rendez vous il y
a une intensité qui est mental surtout
mais qui se répercute sur le physique et
derrière il faut aussi savoir entretenir
son corps russie principal tous de jouer
tout le temps sur le gaz il faut savoir
y faire du sport à côté désistement pour
entretenir sa forme mentale et physique
des sacrifices récompensés comme dans
toutes les compétitions sportives le
vainqueur chez les professionnels à
remporter 1000 euros et des lots ont été
distribués chez les amateurs une
nouvelle édition pourrait être programmé
à versailles prochainement on se quitte
sur ces images le centre alfred de vigny
de voisins-le-bretonneux organisait ce
week-end le neuvième rassemblement
warhammer il s'agit d'un jeu de bataille
fantastique qui se joue avec des
figurines organisé en armée est
également donc des 10 le but étant
d'anéantir son adversaire lors d'une
bataille samedi des parties libres et
des ateliers de peinture de personnages
étaient au programme
un rendez vous organisé comme chaque
année par le club warhammer de
voisins-le-bretonneux des propos
recueillis par nicolas danos organiser
un tel rassemblement permet de d'unifier
les jeunes qui viennent habituellement
au centre alfred de vigny le samedi
après midi deux jours donné pour
certains des responsabilités pour
un tel événement est de faire venir
d'autres personnes qui ne connaissent
pas forcément le monde du warhammer ou
de faire venir d'autres clubs qui
viennent des villes voisines afin de les
faire se rencontrer et puis
éventuellement d'organiser de futurs
événements voilà c'est la fin de ce set
8 journal merci de l'avoir suivi replay
et reportages à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 bonne soirée et excellente semaine à
tous
[Musique]